how come we're not if we're talking 70
000 right you're saying seventy thousand
in twenty twenty statistics came out
that out of the 660 something thousand
people this was public info out of 661
000 people that died from covid five
percent died with covet being the
leading indicator so five percent of 660
you're talking about 33 000 people died
as a leading cause being coveted you're
talking 70 000 died last year leading
cause and opioids how come no one's
calling the alarm how come I don't see
it on CNN Fox MSNBC wise is are they
afraid of bringing it up or is everybody
kind of like Hush Hush because they're
giving us money for campaigns and
commercials well I mean I mean some have
been doing uh documentaries on this I
think there was the Forgotten epidemic I
forget if it was CNN or MSNBC but
understand that when you have privately
fund campaigns that are routinely in the
millions tens of millions maybe hundreds
of millions
um these are largely privately funded
they I mean whether you're right or
whether you're left you are often
getting corporate donations or corporate
interest group donations and
when you have when you take someone's
money it's very difficult to tell them
no or to act contrary to their interest
and these major donors give to both
sides so that whoever ends up in power
they don't mess
they don't mess with those the Health
Care system which right now is very
lucrative and as you probably know
um the United States healthcare industry
is over three trillion dollars a year
um by itself that's the fifth largest
economy in the in the world just the
just health care and what you also might
know is that
we live about the same number of years
as they do in Greece
and they spend a third of that
per person
so it's not like the the patient in the
United States is actually getting a good
return on on the cost so we have a very
expensive system that is not giving us
life expectancy in return and we have a
political system that is often dependent
on private donations and so who when
they make their whichever side gets the
money they don't mess with this system
and there are many calling for reform I
think it wasn't John McCain who called
for campaign Finance reform as well
um sort of getting the money out of
campaigns would then make candidates
more responsive to the needs of a
population as opposed to the needs of
you know corporate imperatives so if you
like this little short clip from an
interview I did click over you to watch
the entire interview and please don't
forget to subscribe to the channel take
care everybody bye
[Music]